Speaker 1: Kelly Lefler, the Republican senator
who lost to Raphael Warnock in Georgia in 2021,
says her organization is going to be
helping out Herschel Walker. I don't
know if that's a promise or a threat from
Kelly Loeffler based on how things went.
She appeared on Fox Business and she
said, We're going to help Herschel.
We're going to help Herschel. Check this out.
Speaker 3: I'm thrilled that Governor Kemp has
thrown his support behind Herschel
really from day one and now he's
throwing his ground game behind it, as are we.
And the key here is that we want everyone to
come in and support this effort. But this effort
is about Georgians. And I'm calling on Georgians
to get involved to support Herschel.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Kelly Loeffler,
she's got a lot of money. Kelly Loeffler and her
husband reportedly are worth about $800 million.
There's no doubt she has money to contribute to
this effort. We have to hope that it's yet another
failure and that the outcome is exactly the same
as the outcome from 2021. Remember, in 2021,
this was because of the 50% rule in Georgia.
Both Georgia Senate seats in 2021 and 2020,
rather, went to special elections,
which took place on January 5th,
2021. We covered them. You may remember
Jon Ossoff won and Raphael Warnock won.
Warnock is the one who faced off against
Kelly Loeffler. Warnock won by 2% of the vote.
It was just under a 100,000 vote margin.
So the hope is the hope is that, again,
some Republicans won't vote because they feel it's
rigged. Listen, I'm not going to go out there and
try to suppress the vote. It's not my move. But
if they want to tell themselves and each other,
don't bother voting because it's rigged and
your vote won't vote won't matter. By all means,
tell each other that that's absolutely fine. And
if indeed the same failed ground game that lost
Kelly Lafleur's election in 2020 2021 is going
to be in play here. I say absolutely fantastic
thing. Let's let them do it. Now, that being
said. You know, no matter what position I take.
A portion of the audience is mad. And this is
this happens with just about every election.
What's my real feeling about this Georgia
runoff? My real feeling is it's probably like
a 55 ish percent chance. Warnock wins 55, maybe
60% chance based on the totality of everything
that's going on and how previous special elections
have gone. Just all these different things.
No matter what numbers ISIS or no matter what
polling I look at, it's always the same thing
with the audience and I think we could much
more productively deal with this. I'm not a
news show. I'm a commentary show. So when you
take a race like this, if I say to you, listen,
the polls are basically split 5050, but based on,
you know, everything from more Republicans died of
COVID than Democrats. So it killed more Republican
voters to special elections in Georgia recently
have been good for the Democratic candidate,
combined with there's maybe some right wing
polls that are averaged in that are not to us.
Okay. Some people will write to me and say, David.
You are dissuading Democratic voters
from voting where you when you say,
I think it's probably a 55 or 60% chance that
Warnock wins. Voters in Georgia will hear that
Democratic voters and they're going to stay
home. It's very dangerous what you're doing.
Okay. If I understate the degree of support,
I get emails from people who say, David and
I got these when I was just looking at polling
with caveats leading up to last week's midterm,
people would email me and say, David, why are
you buying into this right wing narrative that
Republicans are going to do well? It's all push
polling in Georgia. These are trash rightwing
polls. And if voters, Democratic voters here, you
say Walker's leading, they're going to stay home.
First of all, it's a sort of you're damned
if you do, damned if you don't situation. I'm
not creating the polls and I'm not doing news
reporting. I'm synthesizing what's out there
and giving you my opinion, which is, I think
the circumstances slightly favor Warnock. I
don't know whether the polling we have between
now and December six, which is so soon, will
really be trustworthy. It could go either way.
Everyone should vote. That's that's the reality.
Any position can be used to claim that
I'm doing the wrong thing. And by the way,
any position could also be used to say, well, that
means we really should vote, right? If the truth
is, oh, this is 5050 and it's leading red, that's
not a reason for Democrats to stay home. That's a
reason for Democrats to get out to vote. So let's
allow ourselves to recognize simultaneously.
We only have certain numbers of things we can look
at to figure out what is going on. And it's okay
to look at those things. And also, at the end of
the day, cheering and booing doesn't count for
who wins and polling doesn't count for who wins.
Voting counts for who wins. Let's allow ourselves
to understand those things. All right. Make sure
you're following us on Instagram at David Pakman.
Show what's happening, by the way, with the big
announcement tonight. We'll talk about that next